all right
faith hi welcome back
welcome back it's been a month or
probably two months now yeah two months
since you've been here
uh lots has gone on in your life since
then right yeah tell me what's going on
i'm trying to get back into school i'm
staying back at my dad's house
you're saying with your dad in
california city yeah
but i stay in like an rv in the backyard
like i don't stay in the house
is that safe for you my boyfriend's
there so yeah
okay so you left l.a
yes um on
what terms you i mean you left because
you had to or you wanted to or
just because it's too much i don't know
just a lot of drama
you're getting a lot of trouble down
here yeah
the big city is hard for small town girl
yeah
the uh the baby how's the baby
i lost the baby you lost the baby
yeah i'm sorry so it's got to be
disappointing
yeah my boyfriend deangelo was shot
and then the day after he was arrested
and then two days after that i lost the
baby
oh wow it was a rough week he was shot
yeah he got shot in the shoulder and in
the lung
it's a rough neighborhood down there
yeah
and uh one other thing one of the detail
that we
didn't mention that first talk is that
you're at your age is actually 18 not
16.
yes you were a lot of the girls will lie
about their age for different reasons
we don't need to ask why but you're
actually 18.
yes i'm 18. and um so you're living in
california city
what are your plans now well i'm trying
to find a school like
in riverside so once i find a school i'm
going to set everything up i'm just
trying to like
sit somewhere where i don't have to pay
rent or nothing so i can save up my own
money and go get my own spot when i do
find a school
are you still working on and off a
little bit
in bakersfield not out here anymore yeah
okay so bakersfield has
still got a market for that kind of yeah
and uh what do you want to do with
if you go to school what would you like
to study would you like to do i'm going
to study social work
and i'm going to be a victims advocate
that's right you talked about that last
time
and tell me about the crystal meth use
are you still using that or
no not really but after i lost the baby
i was using it because my boyfriend was
still in jail
but since he's been out now and he got
out
on the second so you were you're in la
working figaro street for how long like
three months
three months and what's what what's your
view of it after
that little stint it's burnt out
la is burnt out what do you mean like
it's just
[ __ ] like i don't know just
drama and nonsense a lot of drama a lot
of nonsense for sure
yeah it's it's a it's a rough way to go
through life yeah
yeah i can't imagine doing that for
longer than three months i can't imagine
doing it period but
the longer you're down there the more
you kind of get yeah stuck in that
in that world and you don't know any way
out right yeah
a lot of people have been doing it for
decades it's sad
yeah and where do you think you guys
would settle down huh where would you
guys settle down
would you move to another city or
wherever i find the school
and deangelo is working he's not working
well i just
gotta fly yeah i just got a flyer
for him to apply for a job so because
somewhere
in cal city right now is hiring and
that's where we're at right now
i would have him go work with my uncle
because my uncle owns a fencing company
and my dad works with him but he can't
lift anything right now
because he was shot yeah
would you ever come back to la
maybe to visit but not to stay yeah
too fast huh too fast what do you mean
i mean just it's it's a it's a fast
lifestyle yeah a lot of drugs a lot
a lot of gangs a lot of a lot of
temptations a lot of temptations yeah
is it easier for you up there in
california city yeah
because nobody i know lives out there
anymore
and are drugs available up there too
they're kind of available everywhere
right
yeah but not like in like a big city you
know
like we're a very preserved city like
there's nothing out there
and you have siblings yes i have three
sisters
and one brother so i actually just found
my brother on facebook
and we've been talking was that right
and your sisters are with you
no my one of my two of my sisters are in
cps custody
in oroville california and
my other sister is in oklahoma with her
mom
and my mom is about to get out of prison
in missouri and get a house out there
would you go live with her is that a
possibility um she said
uh she would contact me when she was out
for me to come visit
[Music]
and your sisters are in cps custody
because of why
because my mom already had a case open
with them
but they took the kids from her and gave
them to their father
and their father got into a car accident
not long after
he got them and he died
and then but before that my mom
kidnapped the kids from him
and she got caught and they charged her
with kidnapping wow
lots of drama in your family a lot
like it's all drama yeah
do you feel like the way you grew up you
know with all the
the sexual abuse and just you know
parents in prison and things like that
did you see that that made a difference
in how you
the situation you're in today kind of
you don't know anything different
because that's all you know but
yeah but it it's it's not a convention i
think it makes me want to do better
for myself yeah you said some of that in
the first time yeah
it's admirable that you want to try to
because everybody's like set on me
being like them because that's all i
know yeah nobody takes somebody and i
just want to prove everybody
wrong that's that's a great motivation
and sometimes it takes
that kind of thinking to uh just to
change the
pattern of families that just keep
repeating the same yeah
breaking the cycle break the cycle yeah
it's wonderful
i hope i hope you're successful do you
want to have kids
one day we're still trying yeah
you're young yeah the funniest decades
to do that was deangelo
actually your pimp or would you say he
was no he was my boyfriend he's just a
boyfriend because a lot of pimps are
boyfriends so he was
i know he was very vague but if he was a
pimp he wouldn't be with me now because
i'm not a hustler
i don't i'm not working like that
anymore a little bit
a little bit but not enough of a pimp
around
right right right right so so that makes
him look
yeah look better because he looked like
another
just another boyfriend on figueroa
street yeah
so he seems like a better guy than i
first presumed
i didn't know i mean i was like you know
i'm just going by what i hear and what i
hear from most of these guys is their
boyfriends
yeah yeah so that's good for you
that's good for you you guys gonna get
married we are he already asked my dad
for permission oh congratulations
it's great very exciting
yes
well faith i'm glad you came back it's
nice to hear
some progress in your story i'm sorry
you lost the baby but
i think there's all kinds of uh
wonderful things that can happen for you
especially if you go in this direction i
don't think i was ready i think god just
wanted me to see my opportunities before
giving me a child
hmm yeah you're still learning lessons
what have you learned lately from your
experience in la what have you learned
life isn't all about just looking cool
and pretty and
making people like you it's about liking
yourself and making sure you're okay
before anybody else it's a good one
that's great
all right faith thank you for coming by
again i wish you the best of luck with
school and
marriage and everything else thank you
thank you very much
you